you have never experienced severe  illness you can't understand it even  when you see it  and sometimes that means that when you  see it it makes you angry  so a lot of these poor suffering people  who are chronically ill  who are going i'm hurt i'm hurt i'm hurt  look how hurt i am  people are just like st stop it stop it  stop it right i don't want to be around  that  and it's probably some sort of  evolutionary response to avoid  infection i don't know what it is but  sick people get a lot of hate for being  sick  well it's frustration too on the part of  the people yeah and sadness right and  it's a lot easier to be angry at  somebody than  than sad at them well and to understand  what they're going through you have to  allow yourself to feel that  and sometimes if you can't help it's  easier being mad at them than being like  wow life is so unfair